Okay,
so anyways,
back to the equity thing of all the
postures and idiotic ideas.
So first of all,
to make gender equity across every
dimension of a,
of a,
of an organization,
you have to assume that men and women
have identical interests or,
and,
and temperaments,
and that if they don't,
the state should intervene to bloody
well ensure that they do,
which is something for all you women to
figure out because now there's many,
uh,
many what a positions in society that
women preferentially occupied.
So what are you going to do about that
and what are you going to do about the
Asians because they occupied
preferential positions as well.
You know,
they're overrepresented in all sorts of
professional institutions and the
probability is that that's going to
increase.
What are you going to do about that?
What about the Jews are going to do
about them because they have,
they're in the same position as they
Asians going to put quotas on all those
people.
What kind of stupidity is that?
And then it's worse too,
because let's say you equalize women and
accrued for just for the sake of
argument across all these different
dimensions of society.
Well then what are you going to do it?
You're going to,
are you going to equalize for black
women and Latino Women and Asian women?
Are you going to sub type black women
because it's not like they're all the
same.
Are you going to ensure that women from
lower classes are are represented just
as much as women from upper classes and
how many generations back are you going
to go to check that?
What about intelligence?
What about attractiveness?
How about height?
How about weight?
So the problem with the fractionation by
group identity is that it's endless.
There's no way of ensuring equality
across groups because there's an
infinite number of groups you can
fragment group identity all the way down
into the level of the individual,
which is exactly what you should do.
Which is what we already did in the
West.
We figured,
well,
the ultimate diverse population is a
population of individuals.
So you let the individuals sorted out.
No,
no,
we're going to replace that with group.
Well,
what that means for the bloody social
activists is that they'll be able to
play this game forever because you can
continually fractioning group identity
ad nauseum and so the system will never
be equal and you can bloody well be sure
that as we implement social policy to
make sure that all outcomes are equal,
but the amount of space that you
personally are going to have to maneuver
in is going to shrink and shrink and
shrink and shrink.
We've already seen that happen in many
societies.
You think we would learn from the 20th
century.